[Music]  Real Housewives of Atlanta star Kenya  Moore reveals she's expecting a baby we  will definitely be welcoming a boy or  girl in late this year the 47 year old  reality star made the big announcement  on Sundays Real Housewives of Atlanta  reunion  why I don't want to talk about the  details because I'm just still I'm just  still very nervous about everything and  so I just want to get past a safe place  do you want a boy or a girl I want a  healthy baby  clearly it's a very happy time for Kenya  she tied the knot with husband Mark  daily in June et was first to interview  the couple together at Elton John's AIDS  Foundation Oscars party in March how did  you know this one was the one and vice  versa  great person first date lovely first  sight it was a pretty I knew the first  day yeah I remember calling Cynthia from  the show and saying I just met my  husband it was that kind of chemistry it  really was  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]